my challenge today is to cook a tasty
thanksgiving for one in this air fryer
okay
hey there guys it is me arnold and the
world is obsessed with air fryers i mean
everywhere i turn somebody's got one on
their counter but tasty thought it would
be fun to test me out and see if i can
handle making an entire meal in here and
what better meal than thanksgiving now i
don't think that air fryers are
necessarily gourmet for a kitchen
however i don't think that we should
sacrifice having gourmet food
what i have here is a little bit of room
temperature butter i am adding some
brown sugar to that
a pinch of salt and a little dash of
cinnamon and then i'm also going to take
some oranges and just put the zest right
into this bowl
and i'm just going to mash this all up
just like that
okay now that i have the butter set
aside it's time to tackle this potato
for the hassleback technique not
hasselhoff hasselback all right so what
i have here are chopsticks just good old
take out wooden chopsticks and i'm going
to place them on my cutting board and
what that's going to do is act as a
barrier for my knife so i don't cut all
the way through the potato now i'm going
to cut
almost like more than two-thirds
down
until it hits the chopstick
and there we have it guys my sliced
sweet potato from my hasselback check
that out
now that i have my sweet potato cut i
want to coat it with this compound
butter look at that
try to get some in the crevices if you
can all this butter all the cinnamon the
sweet potato the flavor scream festive
holidays and that is it guys my potato
is coated with my compound butter
yum
i need to preheat it first right so bake
350 seems like a good number is that how
we do this
[Music]
i think that's right while the airfryer
is preheating i went ahead and put foil
onto the rack
there's cardboard inside of this thing i
didn't take it out
look it just beeped that means it's
ready right let's pull this out and see
what magic is happening with this hassle
back ooh
i love how the butter has soaked into
all of the slices of this potato it
looks really really good look at that so
cool
okay guys so look at this one more layer
of butter oh my gosh why not more butter
right it's the holidays every day is a
cheat day during the holidays isn't it
so i'm going to just place my
marshmallows now on top now i'm going to
place this back into
my airfryer for another 15 minutes and
see how it goes oh
check it out guys my hassleback sweet
potatoes with marshmallows on top now
i'm going to add a little bit more
orange zest you know just to be fancy
since we already have a sweet potato
going on i figured i would pull another
favorite of mine brussels sprouts and
turn it into a brussels sprout gratin
right so what i have here are brussels
sprouts and i have some room temperature
butter
gruyere cheese
parmesan cheese thinly sliced white
onion a little bit of salt and a little
bit of pepper
and some garlic powder i'm also going to
drizzle a tiny bit of heavy cream right
into this bowl now i'm just going to
mash this all up together until it's
fully incorporated and that is it my
base for my brussels sprouts gratin so
what i'm going to do here is transfer
all of my goodness into this skillet
just like so
this actually looks really good
wow okay airfryer come on now
all right here we go look at that bubble
bubble
it smells so good but you know what
it's butter and cheese of course it
smells good i have some more parmesan
cheese more gruyere cheese
and i also have fried onions right on
top
look at how good that looks brussels
sprouts gratin yes
to make my stuffing i'm melting some
butter i'm gonna add onions carrots and
celery and i'm just gonna let that cook
down until it's a little soft now i'm
gonna add some thyme
a little bit of sage and some parsley
and then i'm gonna add my instant
stuffing mix and now i'm gonna drizzle
in my chicken stock now i'm just gonna
let this cook down until the stuffing is
no longer dry i'm gonna let it cool down
and that is it guys our filling for the
turkey roulade for my turkey i'm gonna
make a really easy beautiful and
delicious glaze i'm making an apricot
mustard so what i need is some apricot
jam and then i have some grain mustard
like that and then i have some fresh
oranges and i'm just going to squeeze
that juice into this bowl as well i'm
just going to whisk this all together
and there we have it that is my apricot
mustard glaze for my turkey roulade so
i'm going to take this turkey breast and
i'm going to butterfly it in half and
i'm going to split it open right now
take it almost to the edge but not all
the way to the edge and then open it up
like a book
just like that now i'm going to take
some plastic wrap but first i'm going to
wash my hands
and now it's time to release some stress
okay now the goal here is to take it
from half an inch thick to about a
quarter inch thick piece of meat now i'm
going to take my stuffing
and place a nice layer right on top of
the meat look at how good this looks oh
my goodness and now it's time to roll
y'all you ready for this okay let's do
it take the edge of this turkey and just
do a nice little jelly roll of savory
holiday goodness right here okay i'm
gonna get a little chucky with you guys
right now and i'm gonna use this twine
to trust this turkey together so to do
this i'm gonna measure out about five to
six lengths of my turkey then on one end
i'm gonna take this string and tie a
little knot
now i'm going to take
the string and go underneath my turkey
roulade and pull it through
nice and tight yeah you see how it's
kind of getting the shape all nice and
uniform
look at how good that looks right now
i'm going to take this remaining string
and go directly underneath my turkey
bring it up to the top again and bring
it to my first knot that i tied
tie a little bow with this string on the
top and that's it my beautifully trussed
turkey roulade now i'm going to cook it
in the air fryer for about 20 to 30
minutes
okay it's ready it's here let's see
what's up
[Music]
look at that guys
roasted turkey roulade phase one i'm
gonna take this beautiful apricot
mustard glaze and just generously glaze
the whole thing u t
full
okay so now back into the air fryer for
two or three minutes and we're done
it looks really good
wow
gorgeous
so here i'm removing the string
and just doing nice slices oh my gosh
i'm so proud of this
look now it's time to plate this thing
come on thanksgiving more like thanks
living
hello check it out
yes
work
fierce
this airfryer thanksgiving is starting
to look pretty darn tasty i mean i've
got my turkey roulade i have my
hasselback sweet potatoes and i've got
my brussels sprouts gratin
[Music]
so what's left
dessert i'm making apple pie wontons so
what i'm doing here is i'm melting some
butter and i'm going to add some apples
right into this saute pan and on top of
that i'm going to add some brown sugar
a pinch of salt and a hint of cinnamon
i'm also going to add a little bit of
lemon juice and a little sprinkle of
cornstarch to make it nice and sticky
the sugars have cooked down the apples
are nice and tender and everything's
really ooey gooey and sticky this is
perfect filling for my wontons all i
have to do is let it cool down and it's
time to stuff them i have some egg wash
here and i have these store-bought
wonton skins super easy easy to find now
all i'm going to do is take a little bit
of this apple pie filling and place it
right into the middle of my wonton skins
just like that now i'm going to take my
egg and kind of wash the perimeter of
two sides of each wonton skin now i'm
going to take the dry side of the wonton
skin and fold it over press it down and
seal it now i'm going to take some
nonstick spray and just give it a nice
coat on both sides
and now into the air fryer for about two
to three minutes until crispy and golden
brown
oh oh
yeah hello so these look really nice and
crispy but they're kind of dry so i'm
gonna take my spray oil one more time
and do a nice thin coat
that way
my cinnamon and brown sugar can stick on
top of it all right so look at this
that's it my apple pie wontons now as if
that wasn't enough i'm going to take it
to the next level and we're going to
make it a la mode honey we are serving
it with ice cream
yes
well i guess all that's left is my taste
test let's see how i did so this is my
hasselbeck sweet potato that i glaze
with brown sugar and cinnamon and top
with marshmallows
it's like the perfectly roasted sweet
potato it's soft in the middle i have a
nice crispy exterior that orange zest
really does set off the sweetness of the
butter the brown sugar and the cinnamon
okay salivation nation right here my
brussels sprouts gratin
wow
so good now you know what this um
tastes just like any gratin that i would
make in an oven so i don't know if the
airfryer really influenced the final
product but i do know that this dish is
delicious
i'm ready for this one oh yeah baby i am
ready for this turkey roulade oh my gosh
it is visually so stunning
that's what i'm talking about right
there this is a flavor bomb
and finally the moment i've been waiting
for my dessert my apple pie wontons here
we go
okay
there it is
you know what i think this might be the
reason why i'll keep this around
[Laughter]
it's so crispy it totally worked it
tastes like a deep-fried apple pie but
it was done on my countertop
nice work airfryer way to pull through
i really love this challenge thank you
tasty for giving it to me i mean this
airfryer is something else it achieved
all of this greatness with a little bit
of flourish from me
so i'm up for more challenges and if
anybody has any suggestions please drop
it below i'm up for it all right guys i
hope to see you again thank you so much
for joining me and happy thanksgiving
oh yes
[Music]
you